Why You Can't Put Metals in the Microwave
If you’ve ever wondered why there is such
a taboo on putting metals in the microwave,
well, wonder no more.
First, it should be noted that it is not unsafe
to put all metals in the microwave.
Indeed, you often put metals in the microwave
anytime you put a hot pocket in the little
pouch and place it in the microwave.
The pouch has a thin layer of aluminum lining
the inside that is designed to absorb the
microwaves and heat up a bit so as to brown
the outside of the hot pocket.
On top of that, the inside walls of your microwave
oven are made of metal.
If you look closely, you’ll also see that
the window you look at the food through also
has metal mesh lining it.
The holes in this mesh are smaller than the
wavelengths of the electromagnetic radiation
your microwave is producing.
This makes it so the waves can’t pass through
the holes.
Visible light, however, is comprised of much
smaller wavelengths, so that form of radiated
energy passed through the holes just fine,
allowing you to see inside your microwave
while it’s running without getting cooked
yourself.
So if the inside of your microwave is lined
with metal and certain food products, such
as hot pockets and pot-pies, have containers
that contain metal, why does your microwave
manual say not to put metal in the microwave?
First, let’s talk a little about how a microwave
oven actually works.
At its core, a microwave oven is a pretty
simple device.
It’s basically just a magnetron hooked up
to a high voltage source.
This magnetron directs microwaves into a metal
box.
These generated microwaves then bounce around
inside the microwave until they are absorbed
via dielectric loss in various molecules resulting
in the molecules heating up.
Matter that works well here are things such
as water, ceramics, certain polymers, etc.
These all end up converting microwave energy
into heat quite effectively by a process known
as “dielectric heating”.
Basically, molecules such as water molecules
are electric dipoles.
This means that they have a positive charge
and a negative charge on opposite ends.
Thus, they will rotate themselves rapidly
when trying to align themselves with the alternating
electric field from the microwaves.
As these molecules rub against each other,
they heat up and, as they do so, they themselves
also become part of the cooking process, heating
up molecules around them that may not be absorbing
much, or any, of the microwaves.
Metals, on the other hand, are great conductors
of electricity, being packed with electrons
that can move freely.
Depending on the shape/type/thickness/distribution/etc.
of metal, you may observe some heating of
the metal itself in the microwave or none
at all.
You may also observe some arcing of electricity
or none at all.
What’s going on here is that when these
microwaves hit the metal, free electrons on
the surface of the metal end up moving from
side to side very rapidly.
This, in turn, prevents the electric wave
from entering the metal; thus, the waves end
up being reflected instead.
However, there is also the potential that
this ends up creating a sufficient charge
density that the electrical potential in the
metal object exceeds the dielectric breakdown
of air.
When this happens, it will result in arcing
inside your microwave, from that metal to
another electrical conductor with lower potential
(often the wall of the microwave).
In extreme cases, these electrical sparks
can end up damaging the wall by burning small
holes in it.
It can also end up burning out the magnetron
in your microwave oven or, in modern microwaves,
can provide a surge that ends up damaging
sensitive microelectronics, possibly killing
your microwave or making it unsafe to use,
in the case of a hole in the inner metal wall
in your microwave.
Another way it can kill the magnetron of your
microwave is when enough of the generated
microwaves don’t get absorbed, such as if
the food is wrapped in aluminum foil or mostly
enclosed in a metal container or if you just
run the microwave empty for long enough.
On a more mundane level, something like a
spoon or a metal plate or the like, positioned
correctly, will simply make your food potentially
not cook normally.
On that note, once again, it is actually acceptable
to put metal in a microwave under the proper
conditions.
Some microwaves even have metal grates inside
for setting food on, such as is often the
case with certain convection ovens.
There are also certain types of metal pots
and pans that are microwave safe.
These all, however, are carefully designed
to not cause any problems in your microwave
oven.
In general, putting metal in the microwave
is unsafe, not because you are at risk of
bodily harm or the like (though in extreme
cases a fire might be started in your microwave),
but, more to the point, primarily because
it has the potential of damaging your microwave.
Bonus Facts:
• Metal powder at room temperature does
a good job of absorbing microwave radiation.
When it does so, it heats up.
It’s not wholly understood what is going
on here; but it is known that if the metal
particle size is less than 100 micrometers,
the particle will absorb microwaves, instead
of reflecting them.
This is generally how the microwave pouches,
such as come with hot pockets or pot pies,
work; though, they sometimes use a form of
ceramic instead, with the same effect of generating
heat to brown the outside of the food.
These pouches and containers meant for browning
are known as susceptors.
• The type of radiation emitted by microwave
ovens is non-ionizing.
This means that it doesn’t contribute to
your chance of getting cancer like x-rays,
ultraviolet light, etc do.
Outside of potential burn risks, experiments
done with rodents have yet to show any major
adverse effect to prolonged exposure to microwaves
at the 2.45 GHz range seen in most microwave
ovens, even with continual low level exposure.
• The particular band of microwaves produced
by typical microwave ovens (2.45 GHz) was
chosen primarily due to the fact that it is
a frequency set aside for non-communication
uses.
Within the available frequencies that are
not set aside for communication, 2.45 GHz
was chosen because 433.92 MHz would require
expensive equipment to generate sufficient
power to heat food; 5.8 GHz and 24.125 GHz
would require a much higher cost on electricity
used to run the oven; and 915MHz was rejected
as it wasn’t a band available world-wide,
as 2.45 GHz was.
915 MHz, though, is occasionally used in industrial
microwave ovens.
• Electromagnetic waves were predicted by
James Clerk Maxwell in 1864.
It wasn’t until 1888 though that Heinrich
Hertz was able to build a device that was
capable of producing and detecting microwaves.
His device used a horse trough; Leyden jars;
a zinc gutter (worked as an antenna); and
a wrought iron point spark.
• The first known documented use of the
term “microwave” was in 1931 in a Telegraph
& Telephone Journal: “When trials with wavelengths
as low as 18 cm were made known, there was
undisguised surprise that the problem of the
micro-wave had been solved so soon.”
• Even though most microwave ovens let you
choose between power levels, there generally
isn’t any change in the frequency level
of the microwaves being generated.
Rather, it simply changes the duty cycle of
the magnetron.
In other words, it turns on and off at a different
rate.
• A convection oven is basically just a
conventional microwave that also has a way
to brown food like a traditional oven.
In order to provide this browning effect,
the convection oven may use traditional oven
heating elements or might use something such
as a high powered halogen bulb.
• The ability to use microwaves as a heating
device for food was originally discovered
by an engineer by the name of Percy Spencer.
Spencer was working on building magnetrons
for radar sets.
One day, he was standing in front of an active
radar set when he noticed the candy bar he
had in his pocket melted.
Upon noticing this, Spencer made the monumental
mistake of telling other people instead of
keeping it to himself and working on it on
his own.
He and some other experimenters began trying
to heat other food objects, presumably to
get out of actually working while they were
at work.
The first one he heated intentionally was
popcorn.
The second was an egg, which ended up exploding
in the face of one of his co-workers.
Spencer then created what we might call the
first true microwave oven by attaching a high
density electromagnetic field generator which
would then shoot into a metal box, so that
the electromagnetic waves would have no way
to escape and the oven would be much more
efficient and safe.
He then placed various food items in the box
and monitored their temperature to observe
the effect.
The company Spencer was working for, Raytheon,
then filed a patent on October 8, 1945 for
a microwave cooking oven, eventually named
the Radarange.
This first commercial microwave oven was about
6 feet tall and weighed around 750 pounds.
The price tag on these units was about $5000
a piece.
It wasn’t until 1967 that the first microwave
oven that was both relatively affordable ($495)
and reasonably sized (counter-top model) was
available.
Further, it wasn’t until microwave ovens
became extremely popular in the 1970s that
they were commonly known as “microwave ovens”.
Before that, they were typically known as
“electronic ovens”.
• Forks are particularly susceptible to
sparking in a microwave due to the fact that
their tines are relatively close together
and will produce high voltage at the tips.
This voltage will exceed the dielectric breakdown
of air, which is about 3 megavolts per meter.
The air then forms a kind of conductive plasma,
which is the spark you see.
This, in turn, makes the fork an even more
effective antenna for the microwaves, worsening
the problem.
• Microwaves convert Vitamin B12 to an inactive
form, which means about 30-40% of the Vitamin
B12 in microwaved foods is not usable by mammals.
On the other hand, spinach loses about 77%
of its folate when cooked in a normal stove,
but retains nearly all of it when cooked in
a microwave.
In the same way, steamed vegetables, as a
rule, tend to retain more of their nutrients
in a microwave than when cooked in a traditional
oven.
• At one time, most long distance telephone
calls were transmitted via a large network
of microwave radio relay links, such as AT&T’s
“Long Lines”.
In the 1950s, about 5400 telephone calls could
be run through a single microwave channel
via multiplexing.
The distance between hops was typically around
40-50 miles.
The additional cost of transmitting this way
was a large part of why long distance was
so expensive historically.
With the advent and installation of fiber
optic lines and advanced satellite systems,
this made the old ground based microwave relay
links obsolete for transmitting long distance
calls.
(Although, satellite systems are essentially
just a space-based version of this same thing).